the 2018 midterm election is shaping up
to be the most expensive in American
history at least 200 million dollars was
raised in Florida where early voting
ended over the weekend the state saw a
record-breaking turnout with nearly five
million people voting in advance the
large numbers fueled by two high-profile
races dominating the airwaves there
Manuel Bojorquez is in Tallahassee with
more on this story man well good morning
good morning this popular breakfast spot
is a typical campaign stop for
politicians here in Tallahassee this
morning their signs are doing all the
talking now get this nationwide the
midterm election spending figures are
staggering with estimates projecting
more than five billion dollars have
already been spent and that does not
include the 36 gubernatorial elections
the race for governor here in Florida is
a tied one with the Democrat Andrew
Gilliam holding a less than three point
edge over Republican Ron de Santos
president Trump was in Florida once
again this weekend stumping for De
Santis and current Republican Governor
Rick Scott who is challenging incumbent
Democrat Senator Bill Nelson for his
seat that is another tight and bitter
race the tidal wave of dollars injected
into the state has flooded the airwaves
here with political advertising Florida
is home to three of the top ten markets
that have seen the most political ads on
broadcast TV since the beginning of
September we will of course find out
tomorrow whether those ads help motivate
to get voters to the polls
John Manuel thank you